All right, fantastic.
Okay, hello everyone.
Welcome back to the second week, the
third session of the second week of
fundamentals of active inference. So,
I'm Fraser. I'm your host, Fraser. We're
going to be going through chapter one
and appendix A today.
More primarily chapter one, appendix A
is effectively sort of optional
historical material. Very useful, but um
it is it is optional, I would say.
So, let's take a brief Well, first of
all, before we do, are there any
questions before we get started with
anything? Is anyone uncertain about
anything or wants to raise anything?
Maybe a good time to do that just now.
Going once.
Twice.
Nope. Okay.
I'm going to share my screen here, just
the Coda window.
Okay, people should be able to see my
Coda page here. So,
this is chapter one. So, if I go into
This is where we are in the book. If I
go into this the sidebar here, we're
we're in chapter one. What I've done
here is I've just kind of mapped out
um
the key the key themes of chapter one,
the key things to understand
and the what I what I'm calling the
core, preview, deferred, and optional
components of the actual content.
So, as I sort of mentioned in the
onboarding session, core things are
things that we would like to really
understand now in this chapter before we
move on to the next chapters.
And preview are things that are they're
introduced now, but we're maybe not
going to be obliged to understand them
right now, but nevertheless, you know,
we want to start getting a taste for the
ideas, getting a sense about what they
might mean, that kind of thing, with an
understanding that they're not going to
be explained.
There is also this other category,
deferred. These are things that are that
are introduced, but that are only
explained and really should only be
tried attempted to
be understood in later chapters.
And then optional is kind of optional
stuff. So, I think all of all of
appendix A is optional. We you know, we
should discuss some of it today, but
that's not that's not the purpose of
this session. The purpose of this
session, as I have up here, so I've got,
you know, objectives, the chapter in a
nutshell,
the content breakdown as I just
described into the four categories.
And then I have a kind of map of the
chapter, what are the what are the core
things and and their breakdown into
those categories.
And then we have the usual figures and
the questions for this chapter. So, I
think something like this structure
is going to be useful going forward.
We'll obviously see how useful it is,
but that's that's what I landed on just
now.
So, objectives for this session. The the
main objective is this this here. So, we
want to understand the kind of central
story of chapter one is that
perception is inference over hidden
causes of the world.
And then that's formulated in terms of
something called the inverse problem,
but that really is the point of chapter
one. That's what we want to come away
with understanding today. What does that
What does that mean? So, that's what
we're what we're going to be
investigating.
So, I guess in a nutshell, the
the whole story of the chapter is that,
look, the brain, this is in some sense
the
you know, Sanjeev he starts out saying,
"Look, this book is very much about
engineering applications, about actually
creating agents and so on."
on,
but it's useful, at least in the first
chapter, to kind of think about a
specific case, about what we might mean
by an agent. So, we're going to take the
brain as our paradigm case. That's the
idea. So, you know, the whole chapter is
formulated in terms of
neuronal or biological processes very
much. He talks about the brain all over
the place,
but
this is not to presage the idea that the
book is about the brain. It's simply
that this is the the particular example
that he's going to take for this this
opening chapter.
So, that could be a stand-in for any
kind
of agent whatsoever, but it's we're
going to start with the brain.
And the idea is that the brain or an
agent more generally behaves
like a model of some process happening
somewhere. So, that's kind of like
point number one.
But then more particular,
that's that's a that's far too too
broad. More particularly, we have this
idea that
the brain is receiving observations from
the world and it doesn't directly
observe the world. There's some sort of
separation between it and the process in
which it's embed embedded.
And that necessitates that if the brain
is going to reason about the hidden
states of the world,
it has to infer what they are on the
basis of observations that it receives
from the world, okay? So, this is this
is the motivation for inference or why
we even talk about inference at all.
That, broadly speaking, that is what's
known as the inverse problem. So, that's
the kind of
capstone of the chapter, as far as I'm
concerned.
And then this
we introduce Bayes' theorem, Bayes' rule
as a as a formal way
uh
to well, as a way to formalize what it
means to solve the inverse problem and
then to presage later ideas that are
going to come up all the way through the
book. So, that's the chapter in a
nutshell
uh
as far as I can I can see. So,
do we have any questions at this point?
Like the really high-level 30,000-ft
overview so far?
Just quickly see if there's anyone else
who wants to join. No, I think we're
okay.
I'm just curious,
are you
um
do you want to get more into sort of the
inverse problem? I I see there that
you're you have the content breakdown,
so maybe you'll get more into that. It
seems like such a Yeah, we're going to
Yeah.
We're going to do that basically at the
end.
The the inverse problem is the thing
that we build up to in chapter one. So,
there's a bit to get through before we
get there.
All right, well, it doesn't look like
anyone has any questions at this point,
which is good. We'll maybe proceed
through the chapter. So, for the first
the first 20 minutes or so, or maybe 15
minutes,
I'll just briefly kind of explain what I
think is the lay of the land for the
chapter.
Please do interrupt at any point if
people have questions or concerns about
what I'm saying. The whole point is that
this should open up into a discussion,
but of course, in order to have a
discussion, we have to be oriented
enough to understand what we're looking
at in the first place.
So, let's let's
begin our first I'd say I'd say 10
minutes. I'll I'll have a I'll I'll go
on a monologue for 10 minutes and then
people can butt in after that.
So, let's let's think about So, there's
four parts of Well, there's technically
five parts of chapter one. We have 1.1,
like models and representations. So,
what is a model? What is it doing? What
is a representation of a process? That's
the first part of the chapter.
1.2 is this chapter making sense of
order.
Interestingly named. I actually have
some issues with that, but nevertheless,
this is motivating the idea of Bayesian
inference informally. This is what
what's happening there.
And then 1.3, we have Bayes' theorem is
is actually built up for the first time
explicitly
and applied to the particular case at
issue here.
And then we finish off with the inverse
problem as the the capstone of the the
chapter.
That's the lay of the land. That's what
we have to build to.
So, I mean, yeah, the the the book opens
up. Obviously, active inference, this is
a modeling framework for talking about
what the brain or what an agent is doing
at all.
Uh
so, we have to understand what we mean
by models, what we mean by modeling
framework. This is this is how the book
opens, essentially.
So, it doesn't quite open with this
question, although I've put it here,
what are models?
Quite, you know, that's that's a very
important thing to get right.
Very basically, and it's implied
throughout the text that models are
things or processes that make
predictions of one kind or another.
There's all kinds of things that that
could mean, but that's the the bedrock
kind of point of departure for what
we're going to take
the meaning of a model to be. It's
something that makes predictions.
Immediately, there's there's two very
interesting questions that come up here.
All right, well, I've got a model, I'm
modeling some process.
Does that mean that I think that process
is literally constituted by the process
of the model in question?
So, maybe I have a model of Andrew right
here, you know, he's he's on a
two-dimensional surface, as far as I'm
concerned. Does that literally mean that
model is a that Andrew is a
two-dimensional entity? Well, one might
think the answer is no. But it is it is
it's a good enough model for me to be
able to make predictions about what he's
going to do
on the basis of observations that I'm
making about him. So, great.
So, we might think, "Okay, well, maybe
no, maybe Andrew is not literally a
two-dimensional object, but that model
of him is good enough for me to be able
to I will make predictions."
And so, that latter interpretation,
that's what's known as an
instrumentalist perspective. So,
there's
two perspectives about what models are
at all. One of them is realist. We say,
"Okay, the the process literally is this
model thing."
Or explained by precisely what we're
saying the model is. And the
instrumentalist perspective is saying,
"Look, we don't care so much what the
process is in itself, but we can make
predictions on the basis of our model."
So, again, that that wasn't so much
literally in in the opening part of the
text, but I do think it was it's
important cuz this is a this is a
distinction that comes up again and
again throughout the text.
What he does open up with initially is
this question about levels of
granularity of models. So, obviously, I
can have a model to explain some kind of
process.
I immediately have to
kind of think about All right, well, at
what at what level do I want to be able
to make predictions about this process?
Do I care so much about, you know, the
hair of particular people here looking
looking at you with your my interface?
Not really, not too much. You know, a
lot of the time we even don't have our
our video sharing, right? So, if I do
this, you can't see me now, but hey,
look, I am talking, so it's probably
good enough.
I could probably do this entire session
without sharing my video, and it would
it would be good enough.
So that's the question. What like at
what at what level do we want to be able
to
model the the the object of interest?
So
then from there, the those are very
general questions. We start to begin to
presage the ideas of [clears throat]
more particular mathematical ideas. So
we begin with a discussion or mention,
rather, that the the sorts of models
we're going to be working with are
probabilistic.
Probabilistic generative models.
So there's many things that this means
technically. That's again, that's that's
been previewed. We haven't explained
what that means just yet.
And this
>> [snorts]
>> this very quickly, we [clears throat] we
end up with a
one of the main controversies, I would
say, in active inference, actually, is
you know, well, what are we doing when
we're
when we're doing our active inference
modeling?
Are we trying to explain what the brain
does at the global level?
Or are we trying to explain how it does
what it does?
There's constant sort of dispute in the
literature as to what active inference
means in terms of this, you know, one
pole or the other.
And this very much gets back to the
realist and instrumentalist debate about
what modeling
is in general. For the purposes of this
chapter
and indeed for most of the book, we'd
like to maybe think about active
inference models as
you know, they're sort of explaining
what the brain does at a very global
level. So there's particular things that
might be going on in terms of neuronal
processing, but we're not going to take
too many pains to go through, you know,
the labor of understanding what's
happening there. We're going to talk at
a very global level about the agent as a
whole.
That's sort of the point of departure
for active inference, and there
certainly is a lot of
literature looking at,
you know, particular neuronal processes
and so on. But that's that's kind of
getting into the weeds, you know, it's
not really the where active inference
takes its point of departure.
Okay.
Just out of my own curiosity, how many
people here, just raise your hand if you
have actually done some modeling? You've
actually like made a model, a
computational model, let's say, of some
sort of phenomenon. I'm interested out
of curiosity.
I know Andrew does.
Sylvia, yep.
Okay. All right.
Very good, very good. Well, that will
serve you well.
Victoria, yeah. I think that's how I say
your name, Victoria.
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
So that's that's a lot of discussion
about what models are.
The the next sort of
part or or or way that we're getting
into, so we haven't yet got to active
inference. We've talked about what
models are, and we're slowly getting to
models as things that institute active
inference, things that do active
inference. So we haven't quite got to
that point yet.
And he he starts by saying, look,
there's kind of three perspectives on
what models could be or what they could
be implementing aside from the question
of kind of realism and instrumentalism.
And so that we have these three ideas
of, you know, models are collections of
of representations of something. So
they're recapitulating some kind of
relevant structure.
Maybe that's what a model is, okay, in
certain certain interpretations of the
sciences.
There's also this idea of models as
hypothesis testing things, hypothesis
testing machines or or whatever. Or
processes, perhaps, sort of a less
loaded. And indeed this idea goes back
quite a long way
to to, well, a very very long way before
Hermann von Helmholtz, but he was one of
the main
champions of the
idea that perception is this process
[clears throat] of unconscious
inference. So that's that's explicitly
this idea that, you know, the brain is
coming up with hypotheses about what
it's going to observe prior to observing
them. And this is largely an unconscious
process.
So that's another that's another pole
about
what it could mean to implement a model,
what it's actually doing.
And I you know, there's this wonderful
quote from Richard Gregory, perceptions
are hypothesis about what might might be
out there in some sense.
So this is very much in
contradistinction to the
perhaps, you know, late Enlightenment
view that the world writes itself on the
blank canvas of the mind, you know, and
I just kind of have things wash upon me,
and I I observe things, and that's
that's what perception is. This is a
very different view. This is a very
radically different view.
The idea that is that the mind is
actively coming up with explanations as
to what might be out there on the basis
of the sensory data. So it's a bit of a
it's kind of a Copernican revolution in
some sense as to what we think the
process of perception even is. And for
me, certainly for me initially, that was
that was very dis- that was very jarring
and disorienting. So
I've slowly gotten used to it over time.
And the third or
this is not really a a different take on
what models could be doing. This is
really a more
refined
idea about how they do what they're
doing. This last idea is that models are
they're they're ways of measuring
uncertainty. Ways of quantifying
uncertainty about some some given
process. So there's something happening
out there in the world. I want to be
able to predict it. That's what a model
does at all.
And in this latter interpretation,
there's uncertainty associated with my
predictions about the process, and we
like to quantify that uncertainty.
So those are the three very general
domains, let's say, of of modeling.
And we go to there's a wonderful diagram
which I did have up.
I'm not sure if I have it anymore.
Figure, if I go here, this.
It is important to share.
I may not be able to get it in time. I I
quickly changed around some tabs.
But for your for your benefit, at least
I go here.
Figure 1.2, this is
kind of a graphical representation as to
the three interpretations. So actually
that's down here. Aha! There we go.
So, you know,
we have the three interpretations about
what a model is. One is that or
technically the second one is that we're
testing hypotheses about sensory
evidence.
The other is that we have
we're making predictions about what
might be the case on the you know, what
might be out there in some sense. And
the and the the the final one about this
idea of quantifying uncertainty is that
there's some statistical process that we
have that we've made that is reasoning
about the signals, the observations that
are coming in in a way that allows us to
deal with
our uncertainty about what they will be,
especially in the future.
So that, you know, that's that's quite
loose. There's
there's a lot of overlap between those
various interpretations about what
models institute.
But they they are important kind of
handholds on this idea about what a
model is at all, so.
For certainly for the for the
perspective that's maybe most fruitful
for us, it's it's going to be the idea
that the brain is a hypothesis testing
thing. That's that's very much, I would
say, our our point of departure.
So and again, throughout the section,
there was a lot of thing there are a lot
of there's a lot of verbage that's
introduced. Number one, probability.
Number two, inference.
You know,
the these are these are things that are
not fully explained now. That if you
didn't know what they already meant, you
might be a bit confused, but they will
be cashed out
especially in chapter two. We actually
get our hands dirty, and we we we make
some of these models.
Okay.
Yeah, so there's a lot of, you know,
prediction error, inference, Bayesian
inference. These things are mentioned,
but they're not explained. So I
going through this chapter, trying to
tag these ideas, I was thinking, oh my
god, there's a lot of things that are
mentioned sort of, you know,
without explanation
initially. So if you're someone who who
hasn't seen these things before, you
might be a bit overwhelmed.
All right, I've certainly been talking
for more than 10 minutes, and I've only
gone through 1.1.
If people want to
you know
get want me to go faster or want me to
go slower, I I certainly can. But I do
think it's necessary to
have a bit of a general overview as to
what's what's happening before you ask
any questions.
That being said, are there any questions
about chapter one? This well, chapter
subsection 1.1, rather.
Or any any
anything that anyone would like to say
about, you know, their interpretations
of chapter 1.1?
Um
yeah, I would
I would just
Well, just briefly
mention that
I mean, there I think other parts of
this chapter point to it, but uh
sort of
part of the notion behind active
inference
um
is this sort of overturning of this like
historical
um this kind of like scientific history
of like what what a brain does, and
there's been this long-standing kind of
overarching narrative that the the brain
in some ways is just like a passive um
just sort of like this passive uh uh
machine or or or processor that simply
takes in sensory information and then
sort of updates um its knowledge or
something along those lines. So, it kind
of looks like a a bottom-up
uh like one-way approach. And so,
whenever we talk later about the inverse
problem, that in some ways aligns with
that, that there's just simply a forward
mapping of like oh, it's it's bright
outside, so it must be daytime or or
some kind of one-way forward mapping
process. And so, um the issue with that,
of course, is that like we can look at
um
you know, young children who are still
learning about the world and they learn
what a a ball is. Like it's not as
simple as they see the ball, now they
know what the ball is. They have a
singular impression of it and that just
stays as their forward mapping
understanding of what a ball is from
then on. Uh it instead it's that they
have their own prior knowledge or
information. Um they actually engage in
action and so they will pick up the ball
and they'll drop it and they'll throw it
and they'll see what kind of funny
noises it makes and all these other
sorts of things. And so, instead um we
have this kind of like uh bidirectional
relationship. We have the bottom-up
sensory information, but we also take uh
you know, our own prior knowledge of the
world to the situation uh and then
furthermore uh we act on the world in
order to learn, in order to affect the
world, in order to kind of realize our
own beliefs about the world and so on.
So, I'm sure some of that was a little
ambiguous, too, but it's just to say
that uh yeah, there's been not just an
active inference, but other areas of
neuroscience is kind of updating of our
understanding of like oh, this is
actually very bidirectional sort of
thing and then you can see that play out
whenever it comes to like optical
illusions where no one can tell if this
image is of a a duck or a rabbit or
something like that. Like you have these
kind of one-to-many mappings. Uh that
would to where that the classical
forward singular mapping breaks down and
that's kind of what the the inverse
problem is about. So, anyway, I went on
a monologue there, so I'll stop there.
Yeah, no, it's uh as I say, it is a it
is a Copernican revolution in what it
even means to perceive something. So,
yeah, yeah, it's a very very different
style, for sure.
Well, look, really quickly, I just want
to get to the
the main thing before um
the the the latter section, so the
inverse problem. Is he he does a really
good job of motivating the situation
that an an agent or a brain is in by
means of sort of Daniel Dennett's famous
box example.
So, because this, you know, Bayesian
inference
inference more generally, but Bayesian
inference in particular, it can be a
little bit obscure to people kind of
trying to get uh a handle on the
intuition as to, you know, there these
beliefs and they're updating by means of
some sort of process. It can be a bit
strange to uh get inside the head of of
someone who
who
who you know, understand what it means
to to do Bayesian inference. So, Daniel
Dennett has this admittedly contrived
example. There are problems with it,
but it does help to to lay out some of
the core details. So, the main idea is
that let's imagine that you are you're
you're you're inside this box or a
machine or room or something
and you can receive, you know, postcards
from the world in some sense. You've got
some sort of sensory effectors that are
outside of the room and they're maybe
plugged into a terminal or something and
you you can read them on on on this
terminal.
Very nice.
Uh and you can also uh send, you know,
you can emit actions out by means of the
same terminal to the outside world.
But the crucial detail is that you don't
have any direct access to the outside
world. What you get are, you know,
sensor readings on on your screen,
basically. Uh very much as as I am
literally have now in my user interface.
Uh and the the thing is, you have a
particular problem you're trying to
solve in this situation.
You need to try and maintain the
integrity of the box for as long as
possible.
So, you know, that the world presumably
is is relatively dangerous. You know,
you can wander into areas that are that
are going to destroy the box, maybe fall
off a cliff, something like that, who
knows.
Uh and your job is to, on the basis of
the sensory observations that are coming
in from your sensors,
uh
to choose or select the right actions to
perform that give you the observations
that you want to see.
So, presumably you don't want to see the
box uh you know, torn apart or something
like that.
So, this is that's the very general
setup and and idea. This has been
expressed many many times before as well
in slightly different uh verbage.
But this
this makes uh it makes it sort of
immediately
at hand the situation that an agent or
brain is in.
The idea is that there is some world,
there is some state of affairs out
there, some process dynamically
changing, but that the brain does not
have direct access to this. All right,
what it does have direct access to are
observations. Uh some sort of
layer There's there's a layer between
the brain and the the the the ding an
sich, the thing in itself, that is that
is out there.
But nevertheless, we uh the brain can
make predictions about those
observations
that allows it to
uh infer the likely hidden states in the
world that gave rise to those
observations.
That's the that's the key idea there.
So, the idea is that look, in order to
solve this problem, in order to maintain
your integrity across time, you're going
to have to be able to predict what
you're going to observe. Okay? So, it's
not enough that you can observe things.
Very nice. You you need to be able to
perform the right actions that are going
to maintain the integrity of the box.
So, in order to do that, you want to be
able to say look, if I if I go over
there,
you know, there's
a sensor reading here, maybe there's a
cliff there. If I go over there, I'm
going to fall off and and die.
So, I'd like to not do that. So, you
know, I'd like to not observe, you know,
massive velocity changes or acceleration
changes, let's say.
Uh and so that on the basis of that uh
prediction, you can then select actions
that you you think will will give you
the observations that you want.
That's kind of the situation or the the
basic situation that an agent or brain
finds itself in.
And this immediately raise raises a
whole lot of other issues. Especially,
so a big one is this idea of signal to
noise.
So, because I'm not in direct contact
with the world,
I have to go through this vicarious
channel of observations.
The question becomes, okay, well,
is the signal that I'm getting now,
is this does this have information
that's relevant to
inferring what the hidden state of the
world would be or is it just noise? Is
it just, you know, a rustle in in in the
bushes, right?
So, that rustle, that could be a
predator or it could just be wind. So, I
have I sort of have to make a decision.
Am I going to treat that rustle in the
bushes as there's literally a predator
there?
Uh that's my belief about what the
hidden state of the world could be that
generated that observation, or am I
going to pretend no, actually it was
just a it was just the wind, right?
Obviously, there's certain costs
associated with those two alternative um
explanations about the same sensory
evidence.
So, I love that I I I think this is a
very fruitful
um
way to to get into the head space of
what it means to be a brain
brain in this formalism. It's this idea
of the the box, right?
Uh for sure.
And again, there was a lot of things
that were previewed here in terms of
what's going to be coming up in later
chapters. So, things like,
you know,
we can we can then begin to say, all
right, well, if I can predict the
observations that are coming in on the
basis of uh
or like sorry, if I can predict the
states on the basis of the observations,
I can do this for maybe
the present right now.
Or I could do it for you maybe some
amount of time in the future. So, I can
have counter-
factual
uh beliefs about what might happen in
the future if I did certain things. And
this idea of planning then comes up.
But he very very particularly we have
this issue of it's almost always the
case
that across time
you get certain patterns, certain
regularities of observations
that are relatively stable. You know,
for maybe across the entire day,
um
I I I can sort of observe that there are
certain stable patterns. Maybe this is a
rock, this is a tree, right?
Um doesn't matter what it is in itself
in some sense, but
there's there's some underlying
structure, there's some underlying
regularity that that is quite often able
to be exploited by by such agents.
And that's that's a very important
point, that's a very important
observation
that comes up when we start talking
about learning.
Okay? And again, this this idea of
learning, we haven't yet explained what
this means. It's very much taken care of
on in I think chapter
seven, uh I believe.
Uh but again, it's presaged here. So,
especially this idea of learning from
prior information. So, this is very much
where the Bayesian
uh interpretation of um inference is is
beginning to be bootstrapped up. Again,
we talk about the Markov blanket or
that's that's previewed.
This uh Sanjeev has a whole another book
coming out about the Markov blanket or
the free energy principle, so
a lot of the mention of Markov blankets
in this entire book are
are sort of preview for the next book.
Um although that you know, the Markov
blanket is talked about in in in in
later chapters, so.
Now, the really
cut the the
really juicy kernel core of this
chapter, kind of core idea
that's
is then
explicated by means of this kind of box
example is this distinction.
You know, I've I've been using
relatively unformal language so far. So,
there's something out there. There's
something in here. Uh the formal way
that we talk about these things in
active inference is the distinction
between a generative process,
something out there moving around, and a
generative model, so my explanations
about what I think is the case
on the basis of of observations.
This is absolutely core, absolutely
central to to active inference. Really,
everything else is is a consequence of
this idea in some sense.
So, and there's a very common
uh
mode of confusion that that arises with
this distinction here.
So, the general idea is, okay, well, the
process, the thing out there in the
world,
it's got some states. It's got some
structure that is constitutive of it as
opposed to something else.
So, you know, obviously, I as a as a
mammal, I I'd like to have my internal
One of my internal states is that I'd
like to observe
37° C as my internal temperature. That's
a literal state in the physical world.
But, of course, my brain, one might
imagine, has a model about what it it
thinks this state should be.
And the thing in the model is not the
same thing as the
thing in reality.
So, we say that the generative process
has external or true states.
I don't quite like that language, but
that's nevertheless the language that we
use. And the generative model has hidden
or latent states.
And the idea is that what we'd like to
do is we'd like to be able to match up
or have as as little error between the
hidden states and the true states as
possible
in some sense. That's That's very
I I'm I'm literally moving my hands
around, but that's a very uh hand-wavy
explanation so far.
And this this is a very common point of
confusion. A lot of a lot of times,
especially well, myself initially, I I
confused this notion of hidden or latent
states in the generative model
with the external or true states in the
generative process. They're not the
same. Uh they are two different
entities, for sure.
All right. Question, Andrew.
Perfect timing. Yeah,
uh yeah, just to to kind of add to that
um a little bit, because especially
because uh it was some of the questions
in the in the coda about chapter one
sort of hinge on this um this notion of
like internal and external states. Just
that um so
something really important about active
inference, and it almost becomes very
active uh excuse me, almost becomes like
philosophical and gets into sort of
philosophical
debate, and had conversations with like
philosophy professors who
have very different takes on how this
sort of thing works. Um you know, that
active inference in some way lends
towards a sort of uh scientific uh
skepticism in the sense of um
we never have any kind of real true like
somehow like direct access to like the
truth of the environment around us. The
best that we can do is collect sensory
information and then come up with our
own understanding of how the world
around us works. And so, our internal
states
uh or beliefs are in some way sort of
modeling the external uh reality of the
world. This kind of gets into some other
theories in in in cybernetics and and uh
Ross Ashby's theory of the good
regulator theorem, and uh those things
will be mentioned probably in this
textbook a little bit more later. But,
it's just to say, especially with that
the box example that we're given, it's
really trying to highlight like we take
in the sensory information, even though
we can't see outside of the box, right?
So, um
yeah, it's it's just very significant in
that respect. We just we don't have a
clear one-to-one understanding of the
world around us. And in some ways, it's
good that we we don't, because there's
distinct things about us that
differentiate us from the world. Like um
you know, not to paint a bleak sort of
picture here, but I mean, the world
around us doesn't really care if we eat
food, right? I mean, other people do,
sure, but I just it it it it it it it at
the level of sort of natural physics or
otherwise, like the world around us
doesn't necessarily care that we eat
food, but but we do. Like we have to do
that to maintain ourselves. So, there
there is some distinction like, oh, I
live in a world that isn't going to
naturally feed me. I'm going to have to
go do things in this world to to get
food. Like there's always going to be
some degree of difference in what drives
us relative to what's in the world
around us. So,
um yeah, all that is to say that the
internal states in some ways are trying
to model or understand the external
states, but they're never necessarily
equivalent. And you know, there's and
you know, there was a previous
understanding that the the the uh sun
um
revolved around the earth and not the
other way around, right? And and and
from the amount of sensory information
we had and the scientific implements we
had at the time, that seemed to
reconfirm, oh, yes, the sun does revolve
around the earth. We eventually changed
our understanding. Um that helped update
science. It didn't necessarily change
how we dramatically how we live our
lives, um but you know, so it's just to
say we never necessarily have a perfect
understanding of the world around us.
The best we can do is is is this kind of
mediated between our prior knowledge and
the sensory information we receive.
Uh I mean, if I if we took if we took an
instrumentalist uh interpretation about
what it meant to model, then by golly
gosh, I I certainly do think that the
sun uh you know, revolves around the
earth, because for all intents and
purposes, that makes all of the
predictions that I would like to be able
to make good enough. So, again, that's
that's
uh
Yeah, there's all kinds of, you know,
wonderful
um
domains of of being able to look at this
question, uh which I think I think was
the the distinction between realist and
instrumentalist um in some sense.
Yeah. All right. Well, there there is
there is a little bit to say on
um the
epistemic status of of agents in general
in this framework uh towards the end of
the chapter.
We're going to have to maybe power
through in order
to get there, though.
Um okay. Now, what I'd like to just
pause and and ask if anything is
unclear. First of all, who has who has
read chapter one?
Raise your hand if you have read chapter
one.
I know it is uh There we go, Silvia,
fantastic.
Very nice. I have.
All right. MR, very good, very good.
No worries if you haven't. I mean, it
only came out, you know, so long ago,
and we all have very busy lives. So,
good, good, good. Okay, okay, very nice.
Well, let me just um
I will share this picture this uh image
here. So, this is figure 1.3.
This is one of the many representations
of the distinction between generative
model and generative process that will
come up again and again and again
throughout the book.
Um this is the first visual
representation of that. So, there's all
kinds of ways it will will be modified,
but at the the very general level,
there's some process out here. There's
some process in
here, inside the agent.
And the the process outside, the
generative process, produces an
observation that the agent can then
consume.
And its model is what consumes that
observation. On the basis of that
observation, it performs inference. It
changes its belief about what it thinks
the state of the world is like.
But, remember, there's two different
kinds of states. There's the external
state out here in the process.
And there's the internal or latent state
inside the model, and they're not the
same.
And we have no way of knowing if they
are ever the same.
But, again,
do we need to know
if they're the same?
Not really. The only requirement I ever
gave you in that the
the Janet example ever laid upon you was
that, look, all you need to do is
maintain the the boundary that the box
has for as long as possible.
That's the only requirement in this
game. MR, I I see that you have a
question. Uh I don't know if you you're
you've left your hand raised from before
if you if that's a question you'd like
to ask.
Ding ding ding. Now, I'm having to I'm
having to model MR now.
Can he just not hear me or uh
Nevertheless, that's the fin- finitary
predicament we'll find ourselves in.
Do Do try and raise your hand if you
don't have a question, cuz otherwise,
I'll I'll leap in, so.
All right. So, make That was making
sense of water.
1.3 is where we begin to actually get
into some maths, actually get into some
formalization of these hand-wavy ideas
that we've been banding around for a
bit, so.
This is where we preview the idea of
Bayesian inference, more specifically.
So,
thus far in the book, um
first of all, this idea of inference has
been treated
uh
informally, I suppose. Um
Very generally, the idea of inference is
that you've got some sort of beliefs,
and inference is a is a way, typically a
systematic way, of changing your
beliefs.
That's all inference means. And then,
Bayesian inference is a particular kind
of formal way of changing your beliefs.
And this is the basis of the
mathematical formalism that active
inference then builds up in order to be
able to talk about how
we we construct models that do this.
But again, very very
uh previewed and presaged uh right now.
Uh I mean, the idea of probability at
all, this is previewed. Uh this is a
formal way in mathematics of reasoning
about uncertainty.
So, you know, if calculus is the
mathematics of change, then probability
has often been called the mathematics of
uncertainty.
That that hooks in very naturally with
with the third interpretation of what
models are, ways of dealing with
uncertainty.
Um now yeah and this yet again this
issue of kind of realism or
instrumentalism this rears its head. In
chapter one he he says explicitly look
we're going to just assume a very strong
interpretation of the Bayesian brain
hypothesis for chapter one.
Uh
so again what is the Bayesian brain
hypothesis? Very very
quickly this is essentially the idea
that the brain is in some sense
instituting Bayesian inference.
Whether that means we take a realist or
instrumentalist approach to that idea is
is another question.
Um for simplicity we're just going to
assume the realist account is true. So
what does that mean? It means that we
think the brain is literally performing
Bayesian inference calculations on the
basis of probability distributions.
Um there's questions around whether or
not that really is the case but we don't
going to have to we don't we don't want
to have to worry about all that just
now.
makes things a lot simpler.
Raise your hand again if you have seen
Bayes' rule before and if you've used
it.
I'll raise both hands.
Sylvia very nice. Andrew
Excellent excellent. Okay.
Very good very good. Well
I I have labeled this as core Bayes'
theorem.
However there's an important asterisk
there. So Bayes' theorem and Bayesian
inference this certainly is a is a core
idea to active inference.
Absolutely.
However uh
at all active inference models
they do not use Bayes' rule to actually
do calculations.
Uh
there is there is a literal formula
you've probably seen it it's equation
1.2 in the book.
It's composed of these four elements
here.
You can institute this you can you can
use this formula to perform calculations
but it's almost never used
in any active inference simulation or
indeed any calculation.
And there's a reason for that. Uh the
reason
for that is it's effectively too hard.
Um we're going to get into issues about
why it's too hard and what we do instead
to approximate Bayesian inference.
But nevertheless you might think that
Bayes' rule it's something like the
platonic form of correct inference for
Bayesian inference. It's like the
perfect way of changing your beliefs on
the basis of new evidence. But it's not
something that we can actually do except
for the the simplest most trivial cases
that we don't care about.
Um
so that that's the sense in which it's
core. It's it's a it's an ideal.
Um
it's something that we can aspire
towards but in practice we don't
actually ever implement Bayes' rule.
It's it's it's just too hard. It's too
hard to to use.
Uh the the the way in which it's too
hard well there's many senses but the
most difficult of all of the things to
calculate is this very troublesome term
the model evidence.
Uh we're not going to this is this is
very much a previewed idea. I'm not
going to explain what that means just
now.
But
the sense in which it is core is that it
is an ideal and we're going to have to
approximate that ideal and we
approximate that ideal with certain
other mathematical notation which I'm
not even going to explain right now. So
I again equation 1.2
that is it's important to understand
what it is qualitatively.
So I wouldn't get too hung up on the
mathematical notation if you haven't
seen that before but it is important to
to understand that these four things
here. So what what is it made of? It's
made of four things.
It's made of a prior belief. This is a
probability
of being in a particular state of the
world before making any kind of
observation.
A posterior belief.
That's a belief that you have about the
state of the world after making an
observation.
And then it's made of a likelihood and
and this model evidence term.
So this this is really the sense in
which I would recommend you understand
Bayes' rule now at this point in the
book. You don't have to understand the
maths
but the the general meaning of the terms
is is important I would think.
All right 10 minutes left here. So
this you know Bayes' rule is the formal
uh mathematical way in which we go about
changing our beliefs in accordance with
sensory evidence. Indeed it's actually
perfect but you know very sad we can't
use it really for for most interesting
applications. We going to have to have
some kind of approximation to Bayes'
rule and this is where the the cool
sounding free energy enters.
Uh and a little a little bit we're going
to see that in chapter three well a bit
of chapter two and and chapter three.
So what have we what have we said so
far? What have we built towards?
The the thing that we want to be able to
do with our models in active inference
is we want to be able to solve the
inverse problem.
So this is the formal name given to
everything that I've just talked about.
So
what is the problem? Again it's you know
we're in this box. We need to infer what
the states of the world are on the basis
of observations. Those observations
might be noisy. Uh they may be
incomplete
and so on.
But there is we know that there is a way
of using Bayes' rule
to to infer what the state of the world
should be or or is given observations.
And the inverse that that is the inverse
problem. So solving that uh issue that
problem about what what our beliefs
about the state of the world should be
on the basis of sensory evidence that is
the inverse problem. And that's the
problem that every active inference
agent has to solve
in in the course of its
uh
epistemic foraging and and and such
like. So
Andrew did you did you have a question?
I thought you
you raised your hand or you
No okay. I No I did not but I
appreciate what you've said so far. I
mean yeah the the we'll see
an immense amount of Bayes soon to come
and
and in that said yes we're very
frequently not actually going to be
directly using Bayes' rule and we'll
sing see things about how once we start
actually adding multiple variables that
we care about it becomes more of a
multivariate sort of situation. Suddenly
our ability to to compute model evidence
and much of the rest of Bayes' theorem
suddenly becomes
intractable which is the word that's
commonly used and so it just
you know things sort of start exploding
from there or there are these sort of
impossible integrals that we have to to
compute. So
you know this just a brief comment that
it sort of in some ways aligns with the
idea that it's found in a lot of psychia
excuse me psychology and other areas
that
even we frequently will do things like
use heuristics or or you know we have
this Kahneman-Tversky like systems one
and systems two sort of thinking which I
don't I don't fully subscribe to their
particular framework but it really gets
at that and so we'll see things about
variational and approximate um inference
and and sort of all the rest soon to
come. So that's a very good point you
made about how we we're frequently not
going to actually be using exactly
Bayes' theorem even though clearly all
of this is very much inspired by that
and we're doing something like Bayes'
theorem. So anyway. Yeah that's that's
very much kind of active inference in a
nutshell. We're we're doing something
like Bayes'
theorem.
Absolutely yeah. I liked um there's a
couple of good quotes I I singled out on
on page 15 here on the inverse problem.
Um
you know
very much this idea is is you know given
some sensory observation can we invert
this is the language that's used can we
invert that information to determine
what the most likely state of the world
was that generated that.
Uh that that language is used quite a
lot. You know we talk about inverting
the generative model. Um inverting
observations that sort of thing. So that
that that is language or verbiage that's
that's uh I would say preview
for for later later work for sure.
Uh there's a whole other theory to then
be talked about with respect to how much
information we can learn about the world
given observations. There's a whole
branch called information
information theory.
Um that's that's not necessary to
understand now or even for quite a long
time.
And then you know we round out this
section with six really quite excellent
uh questions about
what sort of problems we'd have to
overcome in order to actually institute
to make a generative model.
So all right we know we know what we're
doing when we're making a generative
model. We're solving the inverse
problem.
And we're going to be doing that by
means of something that looks sort of
like Bayes' rule.
All right?
But there's all kinds of problems that
still need to be addressed even within
that very general framework and there's
there's six I haven't listed them here
just now although I will I think I'll go
and put them in the questions table. Uh
I I strongly suggest reading over those
and and really trying to sort of chew
them up and
get a taste of the kinds of problems
that they embody
uh because they're all deeply relevant
for everything else that will be seen.
Uh maybe just quickly so question six
they're all they're all relevant but I
think question six is particularly
relevant.
You know what does the agent do if it
turns out that the inverse problem is so
complex and intractable that it would
take billions of years to solve it?
You know so and he goes on at length and
elaborates that sort of problem. Very
very commonly we're going to find that
the inverse problem is just staggeringly
difficult to solve especially if we're
going to you know
try and and
imagine that we only have one tool
available and that tool is Bayes'
theorem.
Uh so often impossible to actually solve
the inverse problem. So we're going to
have to think about how we're going to
approximate the inverse problem and how
we're going to try and sort of get there
in in in the end.
That is chapter one. That's the the core
ideas, at least as far as I can see
them.
And the the important things I think to
take away from chapter one,
again, the key idea, everything builds
towards this idea that what we're doing
is we're trying to solve this inverse
problem in active inference.
Uh and that specifically is interpreted
as the claim that perception for an
agent is inference about the hidden
states of the world.
That's kind of the the the chapter as as
a whole. So.
I would love, if there are questions, uh
to open it up and uh or perhaps we can
get actually read some of the questions
already placed in chapter one.
But so, if there are if there are live
questions, do uh do not hesitate. I'd
love to take them.
Yeah, I'm just chock-full of questions
today. Uh
I I I just want to briefly say, just
sort of in the spirit of uh appendix A
here, um
and and
hopefully be really quick about it. Um
so,
as far as like the relationship between
a lot of this stuff in in neuroimaging,
um there there's who have done different
kinds of like neuroimaging work. Like,
for example, I've worked with um scalp
EEG uh with with with humans. And so, uh
one thing that we frequently have to do,
whenever we do that in terms of our
assumptions that we're making, say want
to replace an electrode over a
particular area of the scalp, um you're
of course not measuring the the the
microvoltage produced by every single
individual neuron. You're you're instead
kind of making assumptions that like in
this brain region, the the sort of
collective activity of the neurons it it
can can kind of be averaged, and then
that represents potentially the behavior
of, you know, many neurons. And so, I
say all of that because um we can see
just from looking at that alone and
trying to render something like scalp
EEG like actually useful instead of just
saying, "Oh yeah, we have no idea
exactly what this is measuring. It just
might be useful for something." Like, we
we have to have some sort of framework.
And so, um all of these things uh in
relation to that is in part like
whenever we're choosing like what is our
agent in the neuroimaging setting, it's
kind of like, "Oh, our agent is sort of
this this presumed like kind of mean uh
uh approximation of neuronal behavior,
right?" Like, we're always kind of
having to to delimit what is our agent
relative to the environment and and
things like that. And so, I just wanted
to briefly mention that because I think
a lot of people get very excited about
talking about like agents in the sense
of, you know, whether it be robotics or
AI and all the rest, but um this does
have some very important ties back to
just like clearly defining things like
what is your framework, what is your
modeling process, including in areas
where you can't uh you know, sort of
invasively measure the the the activity
of every single
uh particular neuron, right? It's kind
of like this sort of collective agent
made up of many neurons and such. And
that gets at one of the questions there,
too, I think. Question one, did Dr. Nem
Joshi really make the claim about
neurons in the brain, et cetera, et
cetera. So, that's sort of an answer to
that. Anyway, I went on long enough.
Yeah, no, for sure. I mean, a lot of the
time we are, as you say, you know, we we
have a certain kind of technology
available to us, EEG connections of that
kind, and that that measures uh you
know, functional subunits with with some
level of
specificity and granularity that doesn't
kill the patient. Um that's sort of good
enough. That's what we that's what we
have to go off with our modeling with
respect to that issue. Uh um you know,
obviously we'd like
more
um fine-grained modeling potential. A
lot of the time that's, you know, as as
modelers, as scientists, we are in the
position of, you know, there's only so
fine-grained detail that we can even
have with our modeling. So.
But uh engineers and so on, we're a
little bit more
uh
you know, we we can sort of contrive
problems to to whatever level of
granularity we want. So.
Yeah.
I hope that was helpful. I hope that was
not
you know, for those who have who haven't
got the book, I hope that was helpful
with respect to the general idea the
main ideas happening here. Again,
chapter one is there's no there were no
algorithms, there's no real maths of any
kind.
Um it is quite conceptual. There's a lot
of preview material. Chapter two is
where we really begin to get into actual
implementations of generative models. Uh
where we can start, you know,
start playing around with examples and
start playing around with code even.
Uh so, but no, very much the the main
thing to understand about chapter one is
this idea of perception as inference of
hidden causes, I would say.
So, hope that was helpful.
Uh last last uh call for for any live
questions, if there are any.
If there aren't, feel free to put them
into the questions table. You can put
them here
in chapter one questions inside the
chapter one tab, and that will
automatically put them in the questions
table.
Or you can put them in the questions
So, you know, it's it's up to you uh
where where you put them, for sure. So.
Cool. Well, I'll I'll hang around for
maybe, you know, 5 more minutes or so.
But um
alas, that's uh
the
second second second session, second
week uh completed of uh fundamentals of
active inference.
I'll stop the recording now.
Bye.